hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and the final Arc
In Black Clover has just dropped some
massive clues about asta's ultimate
Godly magical power that will allow him
to become the strongest character in
Black Clover and defeat the overpowered
Lucius Tabata has been hinting at this
for a while it involves Yami ichika the
demon slasher Katana dark magic and of
course anti-magic you are not ready for
the truth about asta's true magic power
the final form of anti-magic so let's
get into it you guys know the drill if
you enjoy our Black Clover content and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes you a second but it helps
with that YouTube algorithm and if you
are one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos regularly but haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
big favor and subscribe right now it's
completely free and it helps the channel
out a lot finally this video will
contain Black Clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with question you have
been warned ever since he first arrived
in wano country I mean Hino country Asta
has been undergoing his final training
Arc in particular he has been learning
to control and manipulate his key in new
and unique ways including the advanced
zetan technique and he has been trying
to combine key manipulation with the
power of His anti-magic because key
manipulation isn't something that people
from the Clover kingdom are familiar
with asta's ability to learn these
unique key techniques could give him an
important advantage over Lucius when he
finally returns to the Clover Kingdom
the person who had taken the lead role
in training Asta is yami's little sister
ichika she is of course one of the ReUse
and seven seven of the most powerful
Mages in Hino country and she is able to
combine her unique dark magic with
Advanced key manipulation techniques it
is important to note that there are
different types of zetan and each zetan
user has their own unique style
different users also split their Zen and
powers in different ways and focus them
in on different parts of the body asta's
Big Challenge is to figure out which zet
and technique is the most compatible
with his body and with anti-magic and he
has to figure it out soon it turns out
that the Shogun of Hino country ryuya
does not have any magic but he does have
tengen suit an All-Seeing Eye that can
see everything that's happening at any
given moment this genjutsui I mean
tengansu is how he's been able to
anticipate what's happening all around
him how he knew that Asta was going to
appear in Hino country and so on during
this final training Arc we also learned
that Yami is basically Itachi at the age
of 13 He allegedly massacred the entire
Yami Clan except for his little sister
ichika and then he disappeared the Yami
Clan were a family of legendary
assassins before they were all hitachied
by Yami from what we've seen so far it's
clear that yami's father was abusive but
we don't know anything about the other
clan members this is just a guess but
they probably wanted to overthrow the
Shogun and take control of the Hidden
Leaf Village I mean uh Hino country
hosta doesn't think Yami could ever do
something as brutal as Exterminating his
entire Clan but ichika claims that she
saw him with her own eyes and she hates
him for it but as all of us Shonen fans
know there has to be more to this story
either Yami didn't really eliminate the
clan and ichika just misinterpreted the
situation like someone else made it look
like he did it and ichiga fell for it or
Yami must have had a very good reason to
do what he did we've known Yami for a
long time now and we know that he isn't
the type of person who would just murder
a bunch of people in Cold Blood there is
definitely more to this story but we
will have to wait and see what really
happened with Yami and his clan I just
hope this won't be literally a carbon
copy of hitachi's backstory because
we're getting pretty close here and now
that I think about it ichika totally has
serious Sasuke Vibes anyway as ichika
unleashes her full power against Asta
during their training she reveals that
her dark magic or dark yojutsu works
best when it is combined with martial
arts and sword fighting she also reveals
a technique called Black Star it's
essentially a black sphere or spheres
that generate a gravitational pull and
this pull allows her to create
vulnerabilities in her opponent so she
can use this pull either on her opponent
or herself to make her own movements
wild and unpredictable remember this
technique because it will become
important later for his part Asta
continues to be outmatched by ichika but
just when he thinks that he's finally
figured out the perfect form for his
zetan his training was abruptly stopped
by ryuya ryuya stops the fight because
lucius's paladins have already arrived
in Hino country including sister Lily a
guy that looks like revchi and Heath
Grice yes freaking Heath Grice one of
the very few characters who actually
died in Black Clover and it wasn't a
flashback was brought Back to Life by
Tabata thanks to the power of lucius's
magic Tabata really really really
doesn't like to deal with Death In His
manga and while I can respect that since
he is the mangaka and he can write the
story in whichever way he wants it's
fair to say that all of those no one
dies in Black Clover memes are going to
continue and speaking of no one dying in
Black Clover remember Morris he was like
a mad Magical Scientist character from
the Spade Kingdom Arc he actually looked
like he might be an interesting villain
for like five minutes before lucifero
sacrificed him to open the second Cliff
off gate by draining all of his magic
and life force seemingly killing him
well shockingly he's actually still
alive although he is severely injured
covered in bandages and missing three of
his limbs but Lucius has a plan for
Morris and so he uses the magic of the
dark Triad to instantly heal Morris's
severe injuries just by touching him
Morris's limbs instantly grow back his
cars disappear year and he can even see
for the first time ever as we know
Morris was born blind so he was never
able to see in the traditional sense
Morris is stunned by the extent of
lucius's magical power he realizes that
what Lucius has done goes far beyond
recovery magic Lucius is able to create
and regenerate actual human bodies and
his power is now on par with the power
of a true God lucius's ability to do
this seems to come from the fact that he
trapped Dante Xenon and vanika inside
three magical cocoons and these cocoons
are allowing him to drain their body
bone and blood magic and to use them at
will to create Immortal human bodies
Morris is so impressed with lucius's
godly power that he wants to study it
and conduct experiments but Lucius just
touches Morris's forehead and places him
under his complete control Lucius then
commands Morris to use his magic and
knowledge for the sake of true peace and
the Brain washed Morris agrees
immediately Lucius proceeds to send
three of his paladins to Japan I mean
Hino country which just happens to look
exactly like Japan in our own world for
whatever reason lucious can sense that
Asta is over there training and getting
stronger and his growing strength is
becoming a threat to the world peace
that Lucius has envisioned but sister
Lily then says something interesting she
says that Lucius cannot make a move
right now and that is why the paladins
must be the ones to eliminate this
threat in Hino country and now that I
think about it when we saw Lucius in
that Morris scene he was sitting on his
throne the entire time and he didn't get
up for even a second this could suggest
a weakness or limitation that Lucius is
dealing with something that drains him
of his strength and power for whatever
reason and so he has no choice but to
sit still on his throne and delegate all
the important work to his paladins for
the time being we know that in the past
Lucius was shown to be in a wheelchair
so I'm wonder what's really going on
with him and his body we're not yet sure
what exactly lucius's weakness is but
I'm willing to bet that this weakness is
something that is going to play an
important role in the future when the
paladins arrive in Hino they use Beast
magic to revive the legendary
five-headed dragon of the goshu region
and they vow to make Hino country the
foundation of world peace presumably by
ruthlessly stomping out all potential
opposition as five of the seven to use
and including ichika prepare to battle
against the paladins and the giant
monstrous Dragon Asta is forced to
continue his training by fighting the
strongest of the ryuzen 7. before us
that can enter the battle against the
paladins he has to complete his training
he has to perfect his zetan he has to
master his key and he has to attain a
new ultimate power up and I think I know
exactly what asta's ultimate power up
will be it is of course related to his
own key and anti-mag magic but it is
also related to the dark magic of ichiga
and Yami including their unique
techniques black star and black hole
over a year ago I made a theory video in
which I hypothesized that the ultimate
evolution of asta's anti-magic is going
to be none other than black hole magic
the ability to attract absorb and
neutralize all magical spells objects
and energies now in the real world a
black hole is a region of space-time
where the gravity is so strong that
nothing not even light can escape black
holes can absorb everything around them
including massive objects like stars and
they warp and alter everything in the
immediate area including gravity space
and even time the reason why I really
like the idea of anti-magic evolving
into black hole magic is because we know
that the three strongest devils in Black
Clover possess gravity magic spatial
magic and High magic so since a black
hole has the ability to warp all three
of these things it seems like the
perfect weapon to use against these
three Devils I also like this Theory
because a black hole is a massive
collapsed star and star symbolism and
imagery is constantly present in black
hole there is red star imagery all over
austa's demon form and asta's Main rival
yuno was revealed to possess star magic
so it would be very fitting for Asta to
possess the dark counterpart of star
magic black hole magic and then we have
the black hole and black star spells
associated with the dark magic used by
Yami and ichika dark magic has always
been treated as extremely special and
rare in Black Clover and even back in
the elf Saga dark magic was unique in
its ability to actually hurt a devil
like zagreed dark magic was later
revealed to be connected to the
underworld and that is why yami's magic
was required for opening the gate of the
cliff off Yami has a spell called black
hole which allows him to create a small
black hole that absorbs other magical
spells around it and we already talked
about ichika's spell black star which
also looks like a small black hole or
holes and which has the ability to
manipulate gravity we also already have
a direct connection between asta's
anti-magic and yami's dark magic in the
form of asta's fourth sword the demon
slasher Katana a sword which once
belonged to Yami and was used in
combination with dark magic but which
now belongs to Asta and is being used in
combination with anti-magic with Asta
now also training with ichika and
learning key techniques like zetan it
seems that Tabata is continuing to play
up the connection between Asta and dark
magic and I believe that the ultimate
evolution of asta's power will be a
union of anti-magic and dark magic and
this Union along with Advanced key
techniques will allow Asta to awaken the
ultimate magic in Black Clover a magic
that contains both the properties of
dark magic and anti-magic at the same
time and that is black hole magic in my
old video about black hole magic I also
went into great detail about why I think
that liebe isn't actually a low ranked
devil and I said that he could secretly
be one of the highest ranked Devils even
though he may not realize it himself I
won't get into that here because I
already talked about all the hints and
clues in that video so if you want to
check that out I will link it in the
description the video was actually a
collab between me and Broku and I think
there's a lot of really useful
information there but needless to say if
liebe turned out to be a highest ranked
devil instead of a low ranked one then
the idea that he could help Asta awaken
the ultimate form of magic black hole
magic May makes even more sense so what
would it mean for Asta to unlock Black
Hole magic through a combination of
anti-magic dark magic and advanced key
manipulation techniques we know that a
black hole will absorb everything around
it even light itself and entire stars
and planets can be pulled into it
according to some theories everything
that a black hole absorbs turns into a
gravitational singularity an area where
the space-time curvature becomes
infinite this means that anything that
gets close enough to a black hole will
get sucked into the singularity and
crushed to infinite density black holes
have even been associated with things
like time travel because time is said to
actually slow down in the proximity of a
black hole some physicists have even
suggested that inside a black hole there
exists a regional chaotic space in which
time does not exist like think about it
generating a space in which time magic
would have Zero Effect as hard as all of
this stuff about black holes in real
life is to even imagine it did get me
thinking as I said earlier the three
strongest devils are set to possess
gravity magic spatial magic and time
magic and right now Lucius is in
possession of all of them we know he
possesses time magic even though we
still haven't met the Thai magic devil
we know that he absorbed lucifero's
gravity magic and we know that he also
now possesses the spatial magic of the
elzebub because he was able to Grant
sister Lily the power to use it so
Lucius the final villain in Black Clover
can already use the magic of all three
of the strongest devils in the entire
story so how can anyone defeat this guy
now that he has access to the most
powerful devil magic and to the magic of
the dark Triad which now seemingly
enables him to create Immortal human
bodies instantly heal the most severe
injuries and so on not to mention the
fact that he possesses so all magic
which also is a factor that we can't
forget personally I think that he will
be defeated by Asta combining anti-magic
dark magic and key manipulation to
unlock Black Hole magic since black
holes can alter and warp space time and
gravity black hole magic is the Ultimate
Weapon against the overpowered Lucius I
could totally see Asta getting wrecked
in the final battle against Lucius but
then surpassing his limits and Awakening
black hole magic he will then suddenly
be able to counter all of lucius's
attacks and knowing tamata I can also
see Asta using black hole magic to
absorb some magic from all of his
friends and allies combining it into one
single super move and then releasing it
as an ultimate world breaking attack
that finally takes down Lucius once and
for all that would be such an epic end
to the final battle because it follows
the Shonen formula of the main character
becoming this strongest character in the
end but it also remains consistent with
tabata's formula of including teamwork
as an important part of every battle
what do you guys think will Asta defeat
Lucius by unlocking black hole magic is
there going to be some sort of Epic
Fusion between dark magic and anti-magic
will Yami succeed in rescuing the hidden
Leaf Village don't forget to leave your
thoughts down in the comments below if
you guys enjoyed this Black Clover video
and you want to see more in the future
leave a quick like and comment right now
it only takes you literally a second but
it helps me out a lot and if you're one
of the over 50 percent of people who
watch our videos but haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications the way that YouTube works
even if you watch our videos regularly
you're gonna miss a ton of them if you
don't subscribe and hit the Bell you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar as always thank you guys
guys so much for watching and until next
time see ya Space Cowboys